♪♪
ANTHONY MACKIE
With Sam picking up the shield,
there's a lot of trepidation.
It's surprising how timely this series is.
It's been an
emotional experience.
SEBASTIAN STAN
There's all kinds of actually
complex issues dealt
in this that are very applicable
to the times
that we're in.
MALCOLM SPELLMAN
It really does make you feel like
you've stepped into
something that's bigger than you.
KARI SKOGLAND
The goal was to be very grounded,
so that the super side of it
became embedded in character.
We were inspired by
a team that flies through canyons.
We spent several days
pushing people out of planes.
NATE MOORE
There was a lot of thinking that went into
how to get you into Puerto Rico
and to figure out how to make it work
seamlessly with the
stuff that we'd shot in Prague.
ANTHONY MACKIE
Oh, let's roll again, I'm on!
KARI SKOGLAND
To be here with all the toys
and with the actors who
bring it all alive is just
absolutely overwhelming.
[Laughing]
KARI SKOGLAND
We can't be having this much fun. [Laughs]